je vais être très clair
on a un double objectif
ne pas paralyser le pays et ne pas
laisser flamber l'épidémie et on a un
impératif nous répondons à la demande en
test des français si nous n'étions pas
en mesure de répondre à la demande des
tests des français on nous le
reprocherait c'était le cas il ya deux
ans donc il ya deux ans on nous disait
vous ne laissez pas assez par rapport ce
qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui commence à
monter la petite musique de vous tester
trop c'est pas parce qu'on trouve
beaucoup contestent trop
c'est parce qu'on trouve beaucoup
contestent beaucoup
c'est parce qu'on retrouve beaucoup
contestent beaucoup donc nous avons une
politique de tests qui s'est voulue la
plus ambitieuse possible et qui
permettent aux français d'avoir les
résultats de leurs tests en hold'em dans
le délai le plus bref possible
gratuitement sauf situations
particulières la personnes non vaccinées
qui n'est pas qu'à contacter et qui n'a
pas d'ordonnancé médicale c'est à la
marge
et nous avons voulu une politique de
tests qui se déploient partout et merci
aux pharmaciens merci aux infirmiers
merci évidemment tout ça et c'est aux
médecins qui réalise des tests nous
allons amplifier notre capacité de
réponse à la demande des français en
prenant plusieurs dispositions
complémentaires l'une de ses
dispositions ce sera permettre aux
pharmaciens qui d'ores et déjà vous
savez ont parfois une une tente devant
la pharmacie où on peut se faire tester
une en droit qu'à une seule tente nous
considérons qu'il est pharmacien
souhaite pouvoir employer par exemple
des infirmiers ou d'autres collègues
d'autres collègues soignants et non
soignants kabylité à tester ils ont la
vocation s'ils le souhaitent à ne pas
avoir une seule tente d plusieurs voire
pourquoi pas développer de véritables
barnum de dépistage certains nous le
demande nous allons l'autorisé de la
même manière j'ai signé un arrêté qui
permet aux étudiants en biologie de 3e
et 4e année de tête de réaliser de là
de participer également à la campagne de
dépistage pour pouvoir faciliter la
tâche de ceux qui sont mobilisés depuis
très longtemps et d'augmenter le nombre
de bras disponibles la même manière nous
travaillons tous azimuts pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un maximum de
pharmacie sur le territoire qu'ils
puissent évidemment testé en test
antigénique mais aussi pouvoir dissous
et des boîtes d'autotest je le dis parce
que en difficulté remonté par un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens depuis
quelques jours et notamment je pense à
des parents d'élèves dont les qui devait
faire tester leurs enfants ou avoir des
autotests qui disait c'est compliqué
parfois trouver des autotests de fait
nous avons un retour qui monte environ
deux tiers des pharmacies
met à disposition des autotests rivaux
dire qu'il ya un tiers qui ne qui ne le
fait pas encore donc nous travaillons
avec les pharmaciens pour faire en sorte
que ce soit la totalité des pharmacies
qui demain puissent ils sont au total
sinon vous tombez sur une pharmacie qui
ne redistribue pas il ya toutes les
chances pour que la pharmacie qui soit à
côté elle en distribue il y avait
vendredi de mémoire 6 millions d'autos
teste encore en stock dans les officines
contre 3 millions une semaine avant
c'est à dire que nous avons plutôt
doubler le nombre d'autos tests
disponibles dans les officines maison
n'ont commandé 11 millions pour ce début
de semaine qui fait qu' on est capable
de répondre à la demande donc on
continue à chaque fois de renforcer nos
capacités dépistage maintenant je vous
le dit et on peut se le dire le nombre
de contaminations quotidienne qu'on
enregistre le nombre de cas contacts
hors norme qu'on enregistre il n'est pas
étonnant qu'on soit un nombre de tests
réalisés extrêmement important mais si
nous devions suivre le scénario à
l'anglais ou à l'africaine du sud et que
nous devions commencer à enregistrer une
diminution nous verrons encore une fois
suis très prudent décontamination alors
la pression petit à petit diminuera et
nous redescendrons à des niveaux de
dépistage tels que ceux que nous avons
connus c'est à dire 6 millions vous ne
posez pas de difficulté n'avait pas de
files d'attentes je leur dis vraiment
notre acj ne pas laisser filer le virus
ne pas paralyser le pays et répondre à
la demande
[Musique]